The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: OK.
Today we're all through with
Markov chains, or at least
with finite state
Markov chains.
And we're going on to
renewal processes.
As part of that, we will spend
a good deal of time talking
about the strong law of large
numbers, and convergence with
probability one.
The idea of convergence with
probability one, at least to
me is by far the most difficult
part of the course.
It's very abstract
mathematically.
It looks like it's simple, and
it's one of those things you
start to think you understand
it, and then at a certain
point, you realize
that you don't.
And this has been happening
to me for 20 years now.
I keep thinking I really
understand this idea of
convergence with probability
one, and then I see some
strange example again.
And I say there's something
very peculiar
about this whole idea.
And I'm going to illustrate
that you at the end of the
lecture today.
But for the most part, I will
be talking not so much about
renewal processes, but this
set of mathematical issues
that we have to understand in
order to be able to look at
renewal processes in
the simplest way.
One of the funny things about
the strong law of large
numbers and how it gets applied
to renewal processes
is that although the idea of
convergence with probability
one is sticky and strange, once
you understand it, it is
one of the most easy things
to use there is.
And therefore, once you become
comfortable with it, you can
use it to do things which would
be very hard to do in
any other way.
And because of that, most people
feel they understand it
better than they actually do.
And that's the reason why it
sometimes crops up when you're
least expecting it, and
you find there's
something very peculiar.
OK, so let's start out by
talking a little bit about
renewal processes.
And then talking about this
convergence, and the strong
law of large numbers, and what
it does to all of this.
This is just review.
We talked about arrival
processes when we started
talking about Poisson
processes.
Renewal processes are a special
kind of arrival
processes, and Poisson processes
are a special kind
of renewal process.
So this is something you're
already sort of familiar with.
All of arrival processes, we
will tend to treat in one of
three equivalent ways, which is
the same thing we did with
Poisson processes.
A stochastic process,
we said, is a
family of random variables.
But in this case, we always view
it as three families of
random variables, which
are all related.
And all of which define
the other.
And you jump back and forth from
looking at one to looking
at the other, which is, as you
saw with Poisson processes,
you really want to do this,
because if you stick to only
one way of looking at it, you
really only pick up about a
quarter, or a half
of the picture.
OK.
So this one picture gives us
a relationship between the
arrival epochs of an arrival
process, the inter-arrival
intervals, the x1, x2, x3, and
the counting process, n of t,
and whichever one you use, you
use the one which is easiest,
for whatever you plan to do.
For defining a renewal process,
the easy thing to do
is to look at the inter-arrival
intervals,
because the definition of a
renewal process is it's an
arrival process for which the
interrenewals are independent
and identically distributed.
So any process where the
arrivals, inter-arrivals have
that property are IID.
OK, renewal processes are
characterized, and the name
comes from the idea that you
start over at each interval.
This idea of starting over is
something that we talk about
more later on.
And it's a little bit strange,
and a little bit fishy.
It's like with a Poisson
process, you look at different
intervals, and they're
independent of each other.
And we sort of know what
that means by now.
OK, you look at the arrival
epochs for a Poisson process.
Are they independent
of each other?
Of course not.
The arrival epochs are
the sums of the
inter-arrival intervals.
The inter-arrival intervals
are the things that are
independent.
And the arrival epochs
are the sums of
inter-arrival intervals.
If you know that the first
arrival epoch takes 10 times
longer than its mean, then that
the second arrival epoch
is going to be kind
of long, too.
It's got to be at least 10 times
as long as the mean of
the inter-arrival epochs,
because each arrival epoch is
a sum of these inter-arrival
epochs.
It's the inter-arrival epochs
that are independent.
So when you say that the one
interval is independent of the
other, yes, you know exactly
what you mean.
And the idea is very simple.
It's the same idea here.
But then you start to think you
understand this, and you
start to use it in
a funny way.
And suddenly you're starting to
say that the arrival epochs
are independent from one time
to the other, which they
certainly aren't.
What renewal theory does is it
lets you treat the gross
characteristics of a process
in a very simple and
straightforward way.
So you're breaking up the
process into two sets
of views about it.
One is the long term behavior,
which you treat by renewal
theory, and you use this one
exotic theory in a simple and
straightforward way for every
different process, for every
different renewal process
you look at.
And then you have this usually
incredibly complicated kind of
thing in the inside of
each arrival epoch.
And the nice thing about renewal
theory is it lets you
look at that complicated thing
without worrying about what's
going on outside.
So the local characteristics
can be studied without
worrying about the long
term interactions.
One example of this, and one
of the reasons we are now
looking at Markov chains before
we look at renewal
processes is that a Markov chain
is one of the nicest
examples there is of a renewal
process, when you look at it
in the right way.
If you have a recurrent Markov
chain, then the interval from
one time entering a particularly
recurrent state
until the next time
you enter that
recurrent state is a renewal.
So we look at the sequence of
times at which we enter this
one given state.
Enter state one over here.
We enter state one
again over here.
We enter state one again,
and so forth.
We're ignoring everything
that goes on between
entries to state one.
But every time you enter state
1, you're in the same
situation as you were the last
time you entered state one.
You're in the same situation,
in the sense that the
inter-arrivals from state one
to state one again are
independent of what
they were before.
In other words, when you enter
state one, your successive
state transitions from
there are the same
as they were before.
So it's the same situation as we
saw with Poisson processes,
and it's the same kind of
renewal where when you talk
about renewal, you have to be
very careful about what it is
that's a renewable.
Once you're careful about it,
it's clear what's going on.
One of the things we're going to
find out now is one of the
things that we failed to point
out before when we talked
about finite state and
Markov chains.
One of the most interesting
characteristics is the
expected amount of time from one
entry to a recurrent state
until the next time you enter
that recurrent state is 1 over
pi sub i, where pi sub i is a
steady state probability of
that steady state.
Namely, we didn't do that.
It's a little tricky to do that
in terms of Markov chains
it's almost trivial to do it in
terms of renewal processes.
And what's more, when we do it
in terms of renewal processes,
you will see that it's
obvious, and you will
never forget it.
If we did it in terms of Markov
chains, it would be
some long, tedious derivation,
and you'd get this nice
answer, and you say, why did
that nice answer occur?
And you wouldn't
have any idea.
When you look at renewal
processes, it's
obvious why it happens.
And we'll see why that
is very soon.
Also, after we finish renewal
processes, the next thing
we're going to do is to
talk about accountable
state Markov chains.
Markov chains with accountable,
infinitely
countable set of states.
If you don't have a background
in renewal theory when you
start to look at that, you
get very confused.
So renewal theory will give us
the right tool to look at
those more complicated
Markov chains.
OK.
So we carry from Markov chains
with accountably infinite
state space comes largely
from renewal process.
So yes, we'll be interested
in understanding that.
OK.
Another example is GTM queue.
The text talked a little bit,
and we might have talked in
class a little bit about this
strange notation a queueing
theorist used.
There are always at least three
letters separated by
slashes to talk about
what kind of queue
you're talking about.
The first letter describes the
arrival process for the queue.
G means it's a general rival
process, which doesn't really
mean it's a general
arrival process.
It means the arrival
process is renewal.
Namely, it says the arrival
process is IID,
inter-arrivals.
But you don't know what
their distribution is.
You would call that M if you
meant a Poisson process, which
would mean memory lists,
inter-arrivals.
The second G stands for the
service time distribution.
Again, we assume that no matter
how many servers you
have, no matter how the servers
work, the time to
serve one user is independent
of the time
to serve other users.
But that the distribution of
that time has a general
distribution.
It would be M as you meant a
memory list distribution,
which would mean exponential
distribution.
Finally, the thing at the end
says we're talking about IQ
with M servers.
So the point here is we're
talking about a relatively
complicated thing.
Can you talk about this
in terms of renewals?
Yes, you can, but it's not quite
obvious how to do it.
You would think that the obvious
way of viewing a
complicated queue like this is
to look at what happens from
one busy period to the
next busy period.
You would think the busy periods
would be independent
of each other.
But they're not quite.
Suppose you finish one busy
period, and when you finish
the one busy period, one
customer has just finished
being served.
But at that point, you're in the
middle of the waiting for
the next customer to arrive.
And as that's a general
distribution, the amount of
time you have to wait for that
next customer to arrive
depends on a whole
lot of things in
the previous interval.
So how can you talk about
renewals here?
You talk about renewables by
waiting until that next
arrival comes.
When that next arrival comes to
terminate the idle period
between busy periods, at that
time you're in the same state
that you were in when the whole
thing started before.
When you had the first
arrival come in.
And at that point, you had one a
rival there being served you
go through some long
complicated thing.
Eventually the busy
period is over.
Eventually, then, another
arrival comes in.
And presto, at that point,
you're statistically back
where you started.
You're statistically back where
you started in terms of
all inter-arrival times
at that point.
And we will have to, even
though it's intuitively
obvious that those things are
independent of each other,
we're really going to have to
sort that out a little bit,
because you come upon
many situations
where this is not obvious.
So if you don't know how to
sort it out when it is
obvious, you're not going to
know how to sort it out when
it's not obvious.
But anyway, that's another
example of
where we have renewals.
OK.
We want to talk about
convergence now.
This idea of convergence
with probability one.
It's based on the
idea of numbers
converging to some limit.
And I'm always puzzled about how
much to talk about this,
because all of you, when you
first study calculus, talk
about limits.
Most of you, if you're
engineers, when you talk about
calculus, it goes in one ear and
it goes out the other ear,
because you don't have to
understand this very much.
Because all the things you deal
with, the limits exist
very nicely, and there's
no problem.
So you can ignore it.
And then you hear about these
epsilons and deltas, and I do
the same thing.
I can deal with an epsilon,
but as soon as you have an
epsilon and a delta,
I go into orbit.
I have no idea what's going on
anymore until I sit down and
think about it very,
very carefully.
Fortunately, when we have a
sequence of numbers, we only
have an epsilon.
We don't have a delta.
So things are a little
bit simpler.
I should warn you, though, that
you can't let this go in
one ear and out the other ear,
because at this point, we are
using the convergence of numbers
to be able to talk
about convergence of random
variables, and convergence of
random variables is indeed
not a simple topic.
Convergence of numbers is a
simple topic made complicated
by mathematicians.
Any good mathematician,
when they hear me say
this will be furious.
Because in fact, when you think
about what they've done,
they've taken something which
is simple but looks
complicated, and they've turned
it into something which
looks complicated in another
way, but is really the
simplest way to deal with it.
So let's do that and be done
with it, and then we can start
using it for random variables.
A sequence, b1, b2, b3, so
forth of real numbers.
Real numbers are complex numbers
that doesn't make any
difference, is said to converge
to a limit, b.
If for each real epsilon greater
than zero, is there an
integer M such that bn minus
b is less than or equal to
epsilon for all n greater
than or equal to n?
Now, how many people can look
at that and understand it?
Be honest.
Good.
Some of you can.
How many people look at that,
and their mind just, ah!
How many people are
in that category?
I am.
But if I'm the only
one, that's good.
OK.
There's an equivalent way
to talk about this.
A sequence of numbers, real or
complex, is said to converge
to limit b.
If for each integer k greater
than zero, there's an integer
m of k, such that bn minus b
is less than or equal to 1
over k for all n greater
than or equal to m.
OK.
And the argument there is pick
any epsilon you want to, no
matter how small.
And then you pick a k, such that
1 over k is less than or
equal to epsilon.
According to this definition, bn
minus b less than or equal
to 1 over k ensures that you
have this condition up here
that we're talking about.
When bn minus b is less than
or equal to 1 over k, then
also bn minus b is less than
or equal to epsilon.
In other words, when you look
at this, you're starting to
see what this definition
really means.
Here, you don't really care
about all epsilon.
All you care about is that
this holds true for small
enough epsilon.
And the trouble is there's
no way to specify a
small enough epsilon.
So the only way we can do this
is to say for all epsilon.
But what the argument is is if
you can assert this statement
for a sequence of smaller and
smaller values of epsilon,
that's all you need.
Because as soon as this is true
for one value of epsilon,
it's true for all smaller
values of epsilon.
Now, let me show you a picture
which, unfortunately, there's
a kind of a complicated
picture.
It's the picture that says what
that argument was really
talking about.
So if you don't understand the
picture, you were kidding
yourself when you said you
thought you understood what
the definition said.
So what the picture says,
it's in terms of
this 1 over k business.
It says if you have a sequence
of numbers, b1, b2, b3, excuse
me for insulting you
by talking about
something so trivial.
But believe me, as soon as we
start talking about random
variables, this trivial thing
mixed with so many other
things will start to become less
trivial, and you really
need to understand what
this is saying.
So we're saying if we have a
sequence, b1, b2, b3, b4, b5
and so forth, what that second
idea of convergence says is
that there's an M1 which says
that for all n greater than or
equal to M1, b4, b5, b6, b7
minus b all lies within this
limit here between b plus
1 and b minus 1.
There's a number M2, which says
that as soon as you get
bigger than M of 2, all
these numbers lie
between these two limits.
There's a number M3, which says
all of these numbers lie
between these limits.
So it's saying that, it's
essentially saying that you
can a pipe, and as n increases,
you squeeze this
pipe gradually down.
You don't know how fast you
can squeeze it down when
you're talking about
convergence.
You might have something that
converges very slowly, and
then M1 will be way out here.
M2 will be way over there.
M3 will be off on the
other side of Vassar
Street, and so forth.
But there always is such an
M1, M2, and M3, which says
these numbers are getting
closer and closer to b.
And they're staying closer
and closer to b.
An example, which we'll come
back to, where you don't have
convergence is the following
kind of thing.
b1 is equal to 3/4,
in this case.
b5 is equal to 3/4.
b25 is equal to 3/4.
b5 to the third is equal to 1.
And so forth.
These values at which b sub n is
equal to 3/4, b is equal to
little b plus 3/4 get
more and more rare.
So in some sense, this sequence
here where b2 up to
b4 is zero.
b6 up to b24 is zero
and so forth.
This is some kind of
convergence, also.
But it's not what anyone
would call convergence.
I mean, as far as numbers are
concerned, there's only one
kind of convergence that people
ever talk about, and
it's this kind of convergence
here.
This, although these numbers
are getting close
to b in some sense.
That's not viewed
as convergence.
So here, even though almost all
the numbers are close to
b, they don't stay close
to b, in a sense.
They always pop up at some place
in the future, and that
destroys the whole idea
of convergence.
It destroys most theorems
about convergence.
That's an example where you
don't have convergence.
OK, random variables are really
a lot more complicated
than numbers.
I mean, a random variable is a
function from the sample space
to real numbers.
All of you know that's
not really what a
random variable is.
All of you know that a random
variable is a number that
wiggles around a little bit,
rather than being fixed at
what you ordinarily think of
a number as being, right?
Since that's a very imprecise
notion, and the precise notion
is very complicated, to build up
your intuition about this,
you have to really think hard
about what convergence of
random variables means.
For convergence and
distribution, it's not the
random variables, but the
distribution function of the
random variables
that converge.
In other words, in the
distribution function of z sub
n, where you have a sequence of
random variables, z1, z2,
z3 and so forth, the
distribution function
evaluated at each real value z
converges for each z in the
case where the distribution
function of this final
convergent random variable
is continuous.
We all studied that.
We know what that means now.
For convergence and probability,
we talked about
convergence and probability
in two ways.
One with an epsilon
and a delta.
And then saying for every
epsilon and delta that isn't
big enough, something happens.
And then we saw that it was a
little easier to describe.
It was a little easier to drive
describe by saying the
convergence in probability.
These distribution
functions have to
converge to a unit step.
And that's enough.
They converge to a unit steps
at every z except
where the step is.
We talked about that.
For convergence with probability
one, and this is
the thing we want to talk about
today, this is the one
that sounds so easy, and
which is really tricky.
I don't want to scare
you about this.
If you're not scared about
it to start with, I don't
want to scare you.
But I would like to convince
you that if you think you
understand it and you haven't
spent a lot of time thinking
about it, you're probably
due for a rude
awakening at some point.
So for convergence with
probability one, the set of
sample paths that converge
has probability one.
In other words, the sequence Y1,
Y2 converges to zero with
probability one.
And now I'm going to talk
about converging to zero
rather than converging to
some random variable.
Because if you're interested
in a sequence of random
variables Z1, Z2 that converge
to some other random variable
Z, you can get rid of a lot of
the complication by just
saying, let's define a random
variable y sub n, which is
equal to z sub n minus c.
And then what we're interested
in is do these random
variables y sub n
converged to 0.
We can forget about what it's
converging to, and only worry
about it converging to 0.
OK, so when we do that, this
sequence of random variables
converges to 0 with
probability 1.
If the probability of the set of
sample points for which the
sample path converges to 0.
If that set of sample paths
has probability 1--
namely, for almost everything
in the space, for almost
everything in its peculiar
sense of probability--
if that holds true, then you say
you have convergence with
probability 1.
Now, that looks straightforward,
and I hope it is.
You can memorize it
or do whatever you
want to do with it.
We're going to go on now and
prove an important theorem
about convergence with
probability 1.
I'm going to give a proof here
in class that's a little more
detailed than the proof
I give in the notes.
I don't like to give
proofs in class.
I think it's a lousy idea
because when you're studying a
proof, you have to go
at your own pace.
But the problem is, I
know that students--
and I was once a
student myself,
and I'm still a student.
If I see a proof, I will only
look at enough of it to say,
ah, I get the idea of it.
And then I will stop.
And for this one, you need a
little more than the idea of
it because it's something
we're going to
build on all the time.
So I want to go through
this proof carefully.
And I hope that most of you
will follow most of it.
And the parts of it that you
don't follow, I hope you'll go
back and think about
it, because
this is really important.
OK, so the theorem says, let
this sequence of random
variables satisfy the expected
value of the magnitude of Y
sub n, the sum from n equals 1
to infinity of this is less
than infinity.
As usual there's a
misprint there.
The sum, the expected
value of Yn, the
bracket should be there.
It's supposed to be less
than infinity.
Let me write that down.
The sum from n equals 1 to
infinity of expected value of
the magnitude of Y sub n
is less than infinity.
So it's a finite sum.
So we're talking about these
Yn's when we start talking
about the strong law
of large numbers.
Yn is going to be something like
the sum from n equals 1
to m divided by m.
In other words, it's going to
be the sample average, or
something like that.
And these sample averages, if
you have a mean 0, are going
to get small.
The question is, when you sum
all of these things that are
getting small, do you still get
something which is small?
When you're dealing with the
weak law of large numbers,
it's not necessary that
that sum gets small.
It's only necessary that each
of the terms get small.
Here we're saying, let's
assume also that
this sum gets small.
OK, so we want to prove that
under this condition, all of
these sequences with probability
1 converge to 0,
the individual sequences
converge.
OK, so let's go through
the proof now.
And as I say, I won't do
this to you very often.
But I think for this one,
it's sort of necessary.
OK, so first we'll use the
Markov inequality.
And I'm dealing with a finite
value of m here.
The probability that the sum of
a finite set of these Y sub
n's is greater than alpha is
less than or equal to the
expected value of that
random variable.
Namely, this random
variable here.
Sum from n equals 1 to m of
magnitude of Y sub n.
That's just a random variable.
And the probability that that
random variable is greater
than alpha is less than or equal
to the expected value of
that random variable
divided by alpha.
OK, well now, this quantity here
is increasing in Y sub n.
The magnitude of Y sub n is
a non-negative quantity.
You take the expectation of a
non-negative quantity, if it
has an expectation, which we're
assuming here for this
to be less infinity, all of
these things have to have
expectations.
So as we increase m, this
gets bigger and bigger.
So this quantity here is going
to be less than or equal to
the sum from n equals 1 to
infinity of expected value of
Y sub n divided by alpha.
What I'm being careful about
here is all of the things that
happen when you go from finite
m to infinite m.
And I'm using what you know
about finite m, and then being
very careful about going
to infinite m.
And I'm going to try to explain
why as we do it.
But here, it's straightforward.
The expected value of a finite
sum is equal to the finite sum
of an expected value.
When you go to the limit, m goes
to infinity, you don't
know whether these expected
values exist or not.
You're sort of confused on both
sides of this equation.
So we're sticking to
finite values here.
Then, we're taking this
quantity, going to the limit
as m goes to infinity.
This quantity has to get bigger
and bigger as m goes to
infinity, so this quantity
has to be less
than or equal to this.
This now, for a given alpha,
is just a number.
It's nothing more than a number,
so we can deal with
this pretty easily as we
make alpha big enough.
But for most of the argument,
we're going to view alpha as
being fixed.
OK, so now the probability that
this sum, finite sum is
greater than alpha, is less
than or equal to this.
This was the thing we just
finished proving
on the other page.
This is less than or
equal to that.
That's what I repeated, so I'm
not cheating you at all here.
Now, it's a pain to write
that down all the time.
So let's let the set, A sub m,
be the set of sample points
such that its finite sum
of Y sub n of omega is
greater than alpha.
This is a random--
for each value of omega,
this is just a number.
The sum of the magnitude of Y
sub n is a random variable.
It takes on a numerical
value for every omega
in the sample space.
So A sub m is the set of points
in the sample space for
which this quantity here
is bigger than alpha.
So we can rewrite this
now as just the
probability of A sub m.
So this is equivalent to saying,
the probability of A
sub m is less than or equal
to this number here.
For a fixed alpha,
this is a number.
This is something which
can vary with m.
Since these numbers here now,
now we're dealing with a
sample space, which is
a little strange.
We're talking about sample
points and we're saying, this
number here, this magnitude of Y
sub n at a particular sample
point omega is greater
than or equal to 0.
Therefore, a sub m is a subset
of A sub m plus 1.
In other words, as m gets larger
and larger here, m here
gets larger and larger.
Therefore, this sum here
Therefore, the set of omega for
which this increasing sum
is greater than alpha gets
bigger and bigger.
And that's the thing that we're
saying here, A sub m is
included in A sub m plus 1 for
m greater than or equal to 1.
OK, so the left side of this
quantity here, as a function
of m, is a non-decreasing
bounded
sequence of real numbers.
Yes, the probability
of something
is just a real number.
A probability is a number.
So this quantity here
is a real number.
It's a real number which is
non-decreasing, so it keeps
moving upward.
What I'm trying to do now
is now, I went to
the limit over here.
I want to go to the
limit here.
And so I have a sequence
of numbers in m.
This sequence of numbers
is non-decreasing.
So it's moving up.
Every one of those quantities
is bounded by
this quantity here.
So I have an increasing sequence
of real numbers,
which is bounded on the top.
What happens?
When you have a sequence
of real
numbers which is bounded--
I have a slide to prove this,
but I'm not going to prove it
because it's tedious.
Here we have this probability
which I'm calling A sub m
probability of A sub m.
Here I have the probability of
A sub m plus 1, and so forth.
Here I have this
limit up here.
All of this sequence of numbers,
there's an infinite
sequence of them.
They're all non-decreasing.
They're all bounded by
this number here.
And what happens?
Well, either we go up to there
as a limit or else we stop
sometime earlier as a limit.
I should prove this, but it's
something we use all the time.
It's a sequence of increasing
or non-decreasing numbers.
If it's bounded by something, it
has to have a finite limit.
The limit is less than or
equal to this quantity.
It might be strictly less, but
the limit has to exist.
And the limit has to be less
than or equal to b.
OK, that's what we're
saying here.
When we go to this limit, this
limit of the probability of A
sub m is less than or equal
to this number here.
OK, if I use this property of
nesting intervals, when you
have A sub 1 nested inside of
A sub 2, nested inside of A
sub 3, what we'd like to go
do is go to this limit.
The limit, unfortunately,
doesn't make
any sense in general.
With this property of the
axioms, it's equation number 9
in chapter 1 says that
we can do something
that's almost as good.
What it says that as we go to
this limit here, what we get
is that this limit is
the probability of
this infinite union.
That's equal to the limit
as m goes to infinity of
probability of A sub m.
OK, look up equation 9,
and you'll see that's
exactly what it says.
If you think this is
obvious, it's not.
It ain't obvious at all because
it's not even clear
that this--
well, nothing very much about
this union is clear.
We know that this union must
be a measurable set.
It must have a probability.
We don't know much
more about it.
But anyway, that property tells
us that this is true.
OK, so where we are
at this point.
I don't think I've skip
something, have I?
Oh, no, that's the thing I
didn't want to talk about.
OK, so A sub m is a set
of omega which satisfy
this for finite m.
The probability of this union
is then the union of all of
these quantities over all m.
And this is less than or equal
to this bound that we had.
OK, so I even hate giving proofs
of this sort because
it's a set of simple ideas.
To track down every one
of them is difficult.
The text doesn't track down
every one of them.
And that's what I'm
trying to do here.
We have two possibilities here,
and we're looking at
this limit here.
This limiting sum, which for
each omega is just a sequence,
a non-decreasing sequence
of real numbers.
So one possibility is that this
sequence of real numbers
is bigger than alpha.
The other possibility
is that it's less
than or equal to alpha.
If it's less than or equal to
alpha, then every one of these
numbers is less than or equal
to alpha and omega has to be
not in this union here.
If the sum is bigger than
alpha, then one of the
elements in this set is
bigger than alpha and
omega is in this set.
So what all of that says, and
you're just going to have to
look at that because
it's not--
it's one of these tedious
arguments.
So the probability of omega such
that this sum is greater
than alpha is less than or equal
to this number here.
At this point, we have
made a major change
in what we're doing.
Before we were talking about
numbers like probabilities,
numbers like expected values.
Here, suddenly, we are talking
about sample points.
We're talking about the
probability of a set of sample
points, such that the sum
is greater than alpha.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: I understand how if
the whole sum if less than or
equal than alpha then
every element is.
But did you say that if it's
greater than alpha, then at
least one element is
greater than alpha?
Why is that?
PROFESSOR: Well, because either
the sum is less than or
equal to alpha or it's
greater than alpha.
And if it's less than or equal
to alpha, then omega
is not in this set.
So the alternative is that omega
has to be in this set.
Except the other way of looking
at it is if you have a
sequence of numbers, which is
approaching a limit, and that
limit is bigger than alpha, then
one of the terms has to
be bigger than alpha.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: I think the confusion
is between the
partial sums and the
terms of the sum.
That's what he's confusing.
Does that make sense?
He's saying instead of
each partial sum, not
each term in the sum.
PROFESSOR: Yes.
Except I don't see how that
answers the question.
Except the point here is, if
each partial sum is less than
or equal to alpha, then the
limit has to be less than or
equal to alpha.
That's what I was saying
on the other page.
If you have a sequence of
numbers, which has an upper
bound on them, then you
have to have a limit.
And that limit has to be less
than or equal to alpha.
So that's this case here.
We have a sum of numbers as
we're going to the limit as m
gets larger and larger,
these partial sums
have to go to a limit.
The partial sums are all less
than or equal to alpha.
Then the infinite sum is less
than or equal to alpha, and
omega is not in this set here.
And otherwise, it is.
OK, if I talk more about it,
I'll get more confused.
So I think the slides
are clear.
Now, if we look at the case
where alpha is greater than or
equal to this sum, and we take
the complement of the set, the
probability of the set of omega
for which this sum is
less than or equal
to alpha has--
oh, let's forget about
this for the moment.
If I take the complement of this
set, the probability of
the set of omega, such that the
sum is less than or equal
to alpha, is greater
than 1 minus this
expected value here.
Now I'm saying, let's look at
the case where alpha is big
enough that it's greater
than this number here.
So this probability is greater
than 1 minus this number.
So if the sum is less than or
equal to alpha for any given
omega, then this quantity
here converges.
Now I'm talking about
sample sequences.
I'm saying I have an increasing
sequence of numbers
corresponding to one particular
sample point.
This increasing set of numbers
is less than or equal.
Each element of it is less than
or equal to alpha, so the
limit of it is less than
or equal to alpha.
And what that says is the limit
of Y sub n of omega,
this has to be equal to 0
for that sample point.
This is all the sample
point argument.
And what that says then is the
probability of omega, such
that this limit here is equal
to 0, that's this quantity
here, which is the same as this
quantity, which has to be
greater than this quantity.
This implies this.
Therefore, the probability of
this has to be bigger than
this probability here.
Now, if we let alpha go to
infinity, what that says is
this quantity goes to 0 and the
probability of the set of
omega, such that this limit is
equal to 0, is equal to 1.
I think if I try to spend 20
more minutes talking about
that in more detail, it
won't get any clearer.
It is one of these very tedious
arguments where you
have to sit down and follow
it step by step.
I wrote the steps that's
very carefully.
And at this point, I have
to leave it as it is.
But the theorem has been proven,
at least in what's
written, if not in
what I've said.
OK, let's look at an example
of this now.
Let's look at the example where
these random variables Y
sub n for n greater than or
equal to 1, have this
following property.
It's almost the same as the
sequence of numbers I talked
about before.
But what I'm going
to do now is--
these are not IID random
variables.
If they're IID random variables,
you're never going
to talk about the sum
being finite.
Sum of the expected values
How they behave is that for one
less than or equal to 5,
you pick one of these random
variables in here and make it
equal to 1.
And all the rest
are equal to 0.
From 5 to 25, you pick one of
the random variables, make it
equal to 1, and all the
others are equal to 0.
You choose randomly in here.
From 25 to 125, you pick
one random variable,
set it equal to 1.
All the other random variables,
set it equal to 0,
and so forth forever after.
OK, so what does that say
for the sample points?
If I look at any particular
sample point, what I find is
that there's one occurrence of a
sample value equal to 1 from
here to here.
There's exactly one that's equal
to 1 from here to here.
to 1 from here to way
out here at 125, and so forth.
This is not a sequence of sample
values which converges
because it keeps popping up
to 1 at all these values.
So for every omega, Yn
of omega is 1 for
some n in this interval.
For every j and it's
0 elsewhere.
This Yn of omega doesn't
converge for omega.
So the probability that that
sequence converges
is not 1, it's 0.
So this is a particularly
awful example.
This is a sequence of random
variables, which does not
converge with probability 1.
At the same time, the expected
value of Y sub n is 1 over 5
to the j plus 1 minus
5 to the j.
That's the probability that you
pick that particular n for
a random variable to
be equal to 1.
It's equal to this for 5 to the
j less than or equal to n,
less than 5 to the j plus 1.
When you add up all of these
things, when you add up
expected value of Yn equal
to that over this
interval, you get 1.
When you add it up over the next
interval, which is much,
much bigger, you get 1 again.
When you add it up
over the next
interval, you get 1 again.
So the expected value
of the sum--
the sum of the expected
value of the Y sub
n's is equal to infinity.
And what you wind up with
then is that this
sequence does not converge--
This says the theorem doesn't
apply at all.
This says that the Y sub n of
omega does not converge for
any sample function at all.
This says that according to the
theorem, it doesn't have
to converge.
I mean, when you look at an
example after working very
hard to prove a theorem, you
would like to find that if the
conditions of the theorem are
satisfied what the theorem
says is satisfied also.
Here, the conditions
are not satisfied.
And you also don't
have convergence
with probability 1.
You do have convergence in
probability, however.
So this gives you a nice example
of where you have a
sequence of random variables
that converges in probability.
It converges in probability
because as n gets larger and
larger, the probability that Y
sub n is going to be equal to
anything other than 0 gets
very, very small.
So the limit as n goes to
infinity of the probability
that Y sub n is greater
than epsilon--
for any epsilon greater than 0,
this probability is equal
to 0 for all epsilon.
So this quantity does converge
in probability.
It does not converge
with probability 1.
It's the simplest example I know
of where you don't have
convergence with probability 1
and you do have convergence in
probability.
How about if you're looking at a
sequence of sample averages.
Suppose you're looking at S sub
n over n where S sub n is
a sum of IID random variables.
Can you find an example there
where when you have a--
can you find an example where
this sequence S sub n over n
does converge in probability,
but does not converge with
probability 1?
Unfortunately, that's
very hard to do.
And the reason is the main
theorem, which we will never
get around to proving here is
that if you have a random
variable x, and the expected
value of the magnitude of x is
finite, then the strong law
of large numbers holds.
Also, the weak law of large
numbers holds, which says that
you're not going to find an
example where one holds and
the other doesn't hold.
So you have to go to strange
things like this in order to
get these examples that
you're looking at.
OK, let's now go from
convergence in probability 1
to applying this to the sequence
of random variables
where Y sub n is now equal to
the sum of n IID random
variable divided by n.
Namely, it's the sample average,
and we're looking at
the limit as n goes to infinity
of this sample average.
What's the probability of the
set of sample points for which
this sample path converges
to X bar?
And the theorem says that this
quantity is equal to 1 if the
expected value of X is
less than infinity.
We're not going to prove that,
but what we are going to prove
is that if the expected value
of the fourth moment of X is
finite, then we're going
to prove that
this theorem is true.
OK, when we write this from now
on, we will sometimes get
more terse.
And instead of writing the
probability of an omega in the
set of sample points such that
this limit for a sample point
is equal to X bar, this whole
thing is equal to 1.
We can sometimes write it as
the probability that this
limit, which is now a limit
of Sn of omega over n
is equal to X bar.
But that's equal to 1.
Some people write it even more
tersely as the limit of S sub
n over n is equal to X bar
with probability 1.
This is a very strange statement
here because this--
I mean, what you're saying with
this statement is not
that this limit is equal to
X bar with probability 1.
It's saying, with probability 1,
this limit here exists for
a sample point, and that limit
is equal to X bar.
The thing which makes the strong
law of large numbers
difficult is not proving
that the limit has
a particular value.
If there is a limit, it's
always easy to find
what the value is.
The thing which is difficult is
figuring out whether it has
a limit or not.
So this statement is fine for
people who understand what it
says, but it's kind of
confusing otherwise.
Still more tersely, people talk
about it as Sn over n
goes to limit X bar with
probability 1.
This is probably an even better
way to say it than this
is because this is--
I mean, this says that there's
something strange
in the limit here.
But I would suggest that you
write it this way until you
get used to what it's saying.
Because then, when you write it
this way, you realize that
what you're talking about is
the limit over individual
sample points rather than some
kind of more general limit.
And convergence with probability
1 is always that
sort of convergence.
OK, this strong law and the
idea of convergence with
probability 1 is really pretty
different from the other forms
of convergence.
In the sense that it focuses
directly on sample paths.
The other forms of convergence
focus on things like the
sequence of expected values,
or where the sequence of
probabilities, or sequences of
numbers, which are the things
you're used to dealing with.
Here you're dealing directly
with sample points, and it
makes it more difficult to
talk about the rate of
convergence as n approaches
infinity.
You can't talk about the rate
of convergence here as n
approaches infinity.
If you have any n less than
infinity, if you're only
looking at a finite sequence,
you have no way of saying
whether any of the sample values
over that sequence are
going to converge or whether
they're not going to converge,
because you don't know what
the rest of them are.
So talking about a rate of
convergence with respect to
the strong law of large numbers
doesn't make any sense.
It's connected directly to
the standard notion of a
convergence of a sequence of
numbers when you look at those
numbers applied to
a sample path.
This is what gives the strong
law of large numbers its
power, the fact that it's
related to this standard idea
of convergence.
The standard idea of convergence
is what the whole
theory of analysis
is built on.
And there are some very powerful
things you can do
with analysis.
And it's because convergence is
defined the way that it is.
When we talk about the strong
law of large numbers, we are
locked into that particular
notion of convergence.
And therefore, it's going
to have a lot of power.
We will see this as soon
as we start talking
about renewal theory.
And in fact, we'll see it in
the proof of the strong law
that we're going
to go through.
Most of the heavy lifting with
the strong law of large
numbers has been done by the
analysis of convergence with
probability 1.
The hard thing is this theorem
we've just proven.
And that's tricky.
And I apologize for getting a
little confused about it as we
went through it, and not
explaining all the steps
completely.
But as I said, it's hard
to follow proofs
in real time anyway.
But all of that is done now.
How do we go through the strong
law of large numbers
now if we accept this
convergence
with probability 1?
Well, it turns out to
be pretty easy.
We're going to assume that the
expected value of the fourth
moment of this underlying
random variable
is less than infinity.
So let's look at the expected
value of the sum of n random
variables taken to
the fourth power.
OK, so what is that?
It's the expected value of S
sub n times S sub n times S
sub n times S sub n.
Sub n is the sum of
Xi from 1 to n.
It's also this.
So the expected value of S to
the n fourth is the expected
value of this entire
product here.
I should have a big bracket
around all of that.
If I multiply all of these terms
out, each of these terms
goes from 1 to n, what I'm
going to get is the
sum from 1 to n.
Sum over j from 1 to n.
Sum over k from 1 to n.
And a sum over l from 1 to n.
So I'm going to have the
expected value of X sub i
times X sub j times X
sub k times X sub l.
Let's review what this is.
X sub i is the random variable
for the i-th of these X's.
I have n X's--
X1, X2, X3, up to X sub n.
What I'm trying to find is the
expected value of this sum to
the fourth power.
When you look at the sum of
something, if I look at the
sum of numbers, [INAUDIBLE] of
a sub i, times the sum of b
sub i, I write it as j.
If i just do this, what's
it equal to?
It's equal to the sum over
i and j of a sub
i times a sub j.
I'm doing exactly the same thing
here, but I'm taking the
expected value of it.
That's a finite sum. the
expected value of the sum is
equal to the sum of the
expected values.
So if I look at any particular
value of X--
of this first X here.
Suppose I look at i equals 1 .
I suppose I look at the expected
value of X1 times--
and I'll make this anything
other than 1.
I'll make this anything other
than 1, and this anything
other than 1.
For example, suppose I'm trying
to find the expected
value of X1 times X2
times X10 times X3.
OK, what is that?
Since X1, X2, X3 are all
independent of each other, the
expected value of X1 times the
expected value of all these
other things is the expected
value of X1 conditional on the
values of these other
quantities.
And then I average over all
the other quantities.
Now, if these are independent
random variables, the expected
value of this given the values
of these other quantities is
just the expected value of X1.
I'm dealing with a case where
the expected value of X is
equal to 0.
Assuming X bar equals 0.
So when I pick i equal to 1
and all of these equal to
something other than 1, this
expected value is equal to 0.
That's a whole bunch of expected
values because that
includes j equals 2 to n, k
equals 2 to n, and X sub l
equals 2 to n.
Now, I can do this for X sub i
equals 2, X sub i equals 3,
and so forth.
If i is different from j, and k,
and l, this expected value
is equal to 0.
And the same thing if
X sub j is different
than all the others.
The expected value
is equal to 0.
So how can I get anything
that's nonzero?
Well, if I look at X sub 1 times
X sub 1 times X sub 1
times X sub 1, that
gives me expected
value of X to the fourth.
That's not 0, presumably.
And I have n terms like that.
Well, I'm getting
down to here.
What we have is two kinds
of nonzero terms.
One of them is where i is equal
to j is equal to k is
equal to l.
And then we have X sub i
to the fourth power.
And we're assuming that's
some finite quantity.
That's the basic assumption
we're using here, expected
value of X fourth is
less than infinity.
What other kinds of things
can we have?
Well, if i is equal to j, and
if k is equal to l, then I
have the expected value of Xi
squared times expected value
of Xi squared Xk squared.
What is that?
Xi squared is independent of
Xk squared because i is
unequal to k.
These are independent
random variables.
So I have the expected value
of Xi squared is what?
It's just a variance of X.
This quantity here is the
variance of X also.
So I have the variance of Xi
squared, which is squared.
So I have sigma to
the fourth power.
So those are the only terms that
I have for this second
kind of nonzero term
where Xi--
excuse me. not Xi
is equal to Xj.
That's not what we're
talking about.
Where i is equal to j.
Namely, we have a sum where i
runs from 1 to n, where j runs
from 1 to n, k runs from 1 to
n, and l runs from 1 to n.
What we're looking at is, for
what values of i, j, k, and l
is this quantity
not equal to 0?
We're saying that if i is equal
to j is equal to k is
equal to l, then for all of
those terms, we have the
expected value of X fourth.
For all terms in which i is
equal to j and k is equal to
l, for all of those terms, we
have the expected value of X
sub i quantity squared.
Now, how many of those
terms are there?
Well, x sub i can be
any one of n terms.
x sub j can be any one
of how many terms?
It can't be equal.
i is equal to j, how many
things can k be?
It can't be equal to i because
then we would wind up with X
sub i to the fourth power.
So we're looking at n minus
1 possible values for k, n
possible values for i.
So there are n times n minus
1 of those terms.
I can also have--
let me write in this way.
Times Xk Xl equals k.
I can have those terms.
I can also have Xi
Xj unequal to i.
Xk equal to k and
Xl equal to i.
I can have terms like this.
And that gives me a sigma
fourth term also.
I can also have Xi
Xj unequal to i.
k can be equal to i and
l can be equal to j.
So I really have three
kinds of terms.
I have three times n times n
minus 1 times the expected
value of X squared, this
quantity squared.
So that's the total value of
expected value of S sub n to
the fourth.
It's the n terms for which i is
equal to j is equal to k is
equal to l plus the 3n times n
minus 1 terms in which we have
two pairs of equal terms.
So we have that quantity here.
Now, expected value of X fourth
is the second moment of
the random variable X squared.
So the expected value of X
squared squared is the mean of
X squared squared.
And that's less than or equal to
the variance of X squared,
which is this quantity.
The expected value
of Sn fourth is--
well, actually it's less than
or equal to 3n squared times
the expected value
of X fourth.
And blah, blah, blah, until we
get to 3 times the expected
value of X fourth times the
sum from n equals 1 to
infinity of 1 over n squared.
Now, is that quantity finite
or is it infinite?
Well, let's talk of three
different ways of showing that
this sum is going
to be finite.
One of the ways is that this is
an approximation, a crude
approximation, of the
integral from 1 to
infinity of 1 over X squared.
You know that that integral
is finite.
Another way of doing it is you
already know that if you take
1 over n times 1 over n plus 1,
you know how to sum that.
That sum is finite.
You can bound this by that.
And the other way of doing it is
simply to know that the sum
of 1 over n squared is finite.
So what this says is that the
expected value of S sub n
fourth over n fourth is
less than infinity.
That says that the probability
of the set of omega for which
S to the fourth over n fourth
is equal to 0 is equal to 1.
in other words, it's saying
that S to the fourth over
omega over n fourth
converges to 0.
That's not quite what
we want, is it?
But the set of sample points
for which this quantity
converges has probability 1.
And here is where you see the
real power of the strong law
of large numbers.
Because if these numbers
converge to 0 with probability
1, what happens to the set of
numbers is Sn to the fourth of
omega divided by n to the
fourth, this limit--
if this was equal to 0, then
what is the limit as n
approaches infinity of Sn of
omega over n to the fourth?
If I take the fourth root
of this, I get this.
If this quantity is converging
to 0, the fourth root of this
also has to be converging to 0
on a sample path basis of the
fact that this converges means
that this converges also.
Now, you see if you were dealing
with convergence in
probability or something like
that, you couldn't play this
funny game.
And the ability to play this
game is really what makes
convergence in probability
a powerful concept.
You can do all sorts of strange
things with it.
And we'll talk about
that next time.
But that's why all
of this works.
So that's what says that the
probability of the set of
omega for which the limits
of Sn of omega over n
equals 0 equals 1.
Now, let's look at the
strange aspect of
what we've just done.
And this is where things
get very peculiar.
Let's look at the Bernoulli
case, which by now we all
understand.
So we consider a Bernoulli
process, all
moments of X exist.
Moment-generating functions
of X exist.
X is about as well-behaved as
you can expect because it only
has the values 1 or 0.
So it's very nice.
The expected value of X
is going to be equal
to p in this case.
The set of sample paths for
which Sn of omega over n is
equal to p has probability 1.
In other words, with probability
1, when you look
at a sample path and you look
at the whole thing from n
equals 1 off to infinity, and
you take the limit of that
sample path as n goes to
infinity, what you get is p.
And the probability that you
get p is equal to 1.
Well, now, the thing that's
disturbing is, if you look at
another Bernoulli process where
the probability of the 1
is p prime instead of p.
What happens then?
With probability 1, you get
convergence of Sn of omega
over n, but the convergence is
to p prime instead of to p.
The events in these two spaces
are exactly the same.
We've changed the probability
measure, but we've kept all
the events the same.
And by changing the probability
measure, we have
changed one set of probability 1
into a set of probability 0.
And we changed another set of
probability 0 into set of
probability 1.
So we have two different
events here.
On one probability measure, this
event has probability 1.
On the other one, it
has probability 0.
They're both very nice, very
well-behaved probabilistic
situations.
So that's a little disturbing.
But then you say, you can pick
p in an uncountably infinite
number of ways.
And for each way you
count p, you have
uncountably many events.
Excuse me, for each value of
p, you have one event of
probability 1 for that p.
So as you go through this
uncountable number of events,
you go through this uncountable
number of p's, you
have an uncountable number of
events, each of which has
probability 1 for its own p.
And now the set of sequences
that converge is, in fact, a
rather peculiar sequence
to start with.
So if you look at all the other
things that are going to
happen, there are an awful
lot of those events also.
So what is happening here is
that these events that we're
talking about are indeed very,
very peculiar events.
I mean, all the mathematics
works out.
The mathematics is fine.
There's no doubt about it.
In fact, the mathematics
of probability
theory was worked out.
People like Kolmogorov went to
great efforts to make sure
that all of this worked out.
But then he wound up with
this peculiar kind
of situation here.
And that's what happens when you
go to an infinite number
of random variables.
And it's ugly, but that's
the way it is.
So that what I'm arguing here
is that when you go from
finite m to infinite n, and
you start interchanging
limits, and you start taking
limits without much care and
you start doing all the things
that you would like to do,
thinking that infinite n is sort
of the same as finite n.
In most places in probability,
you can do that and you can
away with it.
As soon as you start dealing
with the strong law of large
numbers, you suddenly really
have to start being careful
about this.
So from now on, we have to be
just a little bit careful
about interchanging limits,
interchanging summation and
integration, interchanging all
sorts of things, as soon as we
have an infinite number
of random variables.
So that's a care that we have
to worry about from here on.
OK, thank you.